le cycliste hugo l'autoproclamé c'était
quoi le goût de l'équipe astana dont il
est à peine revenu de son premier tour
de france qui vont monter en vélo en fin
de semaine
toujours avec la même équipe pour les
grands prix cyclistes du québec et de
montréal et des épreuves du world tour
est avec nous ce matin un studio bonjour
bon match fini de somme vous avez vous
n'êtes pas l'ami le gone de l'équipe
vous aviez une fonction très précises ne
reviendra pas sur les détails
vous avez vécu toute une expérience cet
été avec le tour de france aura
effectivement toute une expérience au
tour de france
c'est ce que je peux être un goon de
cyclisme et certainement pas ok parce
que avec la robe mes épaules fait un peu
loin mais c'est vrai que tu es là pour
protéger mes leaders fait que c'est un
peu pour ce qu'on appelle comme ça et
c'est la deuxième fois que les grands
prix ce qu'ils vont avoir lieu à québec
et à montréal ce sont les deux seules
épreuves majeures classe et u6 du world
tour qui sont présentes en amérique
comment sont perçus ces deux courses là
par les européens qui viennent ici c'est
une course qui jouit d'une très bonne
réputation tout le monde se bat pour
nous à chaque année parce que l'accueil
est vraiment exceptionnel on a deux
beaux parcours à québec et à montréal la
foule est toujours présente
on est bien logés on notait au château
les années précédentes et puis tout le
monde a envie de venir c'est la dernière
préparation pour les championnats du
monde qui ont lieu deux semaines plus
tard donc cette année déjà on voit les
meilleurs
sagan alaphilippe qui était maillot
jaune pendant dix jours au tour de
france donc c'est ce que vous avez la
crème de la crème ici pour le week-end
c'est exceptionnel que les grands prix
cyclistes russie ce afin d'amener les
européens au québec c'est quelque chose
qui est difficile à faire parce que les
gosses veulent pas trop voyager
justement deux semaines des décharges
non mais ça vaut le voyage donc j'espère
que les spectateurs vont être le présent
pour encourager les gueules qui en fait
le voyage avec du bon temps à du beau
temps avec la crème d'astana aussi il ya
une excellente nouvelle en ce qui
concerne le mode à la jack up wolson qui
a une prolongation de contrat de deux
ans en votre cas aussi une bonne
nouvelle qui va être annoncé aujourd'hui
la sortie ce matin à midi hors d'europe
j'ai une prolonger mon entente de trois
ans avec l'équipe fazzt en protéines
donc c'est une belle marque de confiance
et pas beaucoup de choses sur le coureur
dans l'équipe tient contre 3,1 pour
jusqu'en 2022
donc pour moi c'est un bel
accomplissement paie aussi ça me donne
la sécurité pour la suite j'ai vraiment
trouvé
ma maison là là le sens où l'équipe m'a
fait confiance maintenant mis à
disposition pour aller donner le
meilleur de moi même je me suis fait de
bons amis à vous donc pour les néophytes
ça veut dire quoi les meilleures
conditions de travail pour un coureur
comme vous savez desquels on a un
programme de course qui est déterminé à
l'avancé on peut se préparer pour les
grands événements il bouscule pas notre
programme et des dates bien d'arrêter
les telle course et amène sur des stages
d'entraînement comme cette année pour
préparer le tour de france j'ai fait
deux semaines à tenerife a t d en haut
du volcan 2100 mah d'altitude je t'aime
fait du bon travail avec les entraîneurs
qui étaient sur place
monitorer chaque entraînement avec le
massage après chaque séance l'ostéo
manning on a fait un rappel après
l'extrême sud où finit encore deux
semaines à isola 2000 en altitude
donc toutes ces étapes le font en sorte
que tu peux arriver au top de ta forme
pour l'événement ce n'est pas tout les
équipes où tous les coureurs qui ont
accès à ce genre de stage ça démontre un
peu l'importance que qui m'est accordée
et puis moi ça me fait chaud au coeur de
me dévouer pour l'équipe toute l'année
mais qu'à kehl et les résultats suivent
puis que l'équipement mais témoigne de
la confiance en fin d'année avec un bon
contrôle se fait ça fait plaisir ça veut
peut-être dire un deuxième tour de
france en 2020 pour pour vous je veux
venir sur le tour de france est quelque
chose qui nous a étonnés
vous avez accordé des entrevues presque
à chaque jour après chacune des étapes
marc-andré bon on n'en revenait pas on
n'avait jamais vu ça c'est quoi une
façon de décompresser de sortir du
cirque du tour de france pour pourquoi
cet engouement pour nous tout d'un coup
non mais il y avait eu avec l'intérêt de
votre temps ça me faisait plaisir
d'essayer de faire connaître un peu de
cyclistes ce travail le québec le canada
à travers mon expérience au tour de
france
évidemment ce n'est pas toujours facile
en déplacement dans le bus entre les
étapes mais j'essayais l'accommoder son
meilleur passé avec moi puis la fatigue
s'accumule m et surtout deux fois vivre
un peu l'expérience pour transmettre la
passion cycliste qui est un peu méconnu
au québec par rapport à tout ce qu'on
voit au tour de france c'est ce qui fait
le tour de france exceptionnel tout les
gens qui sont sur le banc la route qui
nous encouragent la culture derrière le
tout si on peut transmettre un petit peu
au québec plus hachée que les gens
bougeaient plus en plus prendre le vélo
s'entraîne il ya plein de beaux défis ou
fin de la saison donc c'est un peu le
derrière celle que des gens qui autour
du des circuits en fin de semaine vont
un peu pédaler avec vous ça va vous
donner ça va ça vous ça vous êtes
certainement j'ai été le premier surpris
l'année dernière j'avais vraiment la
foule était derrière moi scander mon nom
que ce soit à québec ou à montréal
c'était assez impressionnant
donc je les remercie pour ce que ça fait
ça fait chaud au coeur puis ça ça nous
donne la petite guerre de plus dans le
final pour pour faire la différence
cette année j'arrive en forme je pense
que je vois plus de liberté de la part
de l'équipe astana donc j'espère être en
mesure d'aller chercher un résultat
significatif le ici que ce soit à québec
ou à montréal
jude law est ce qu est ce que c'est la
même règle est ce que vous vous protégez
la vence du coureur du leader de
l'équipe j'ai plus de liberté d'aller
chez là il va plus de liberté pour moi
mais ça ce projet leadership aussi j'ai
pas encore le plan de performance mais
je m'attends à voir beaucoup de liberté
ne pas avoir à travailler pour quelqu'un
d'eau donc juste d'avoir ma chance c'est
déjà une belle marque de confiance plus
cher de même essayer comme on dit
évidemment ses meilleurs au monde je me
suis fait demander est ce que tu penses
que tu vas gagner ça va être compliqué
mon si oui on va essayer je pense que
c'est un bon niveau j'ai démontré en
norvège et finit cinquième c'est
toujours devant
la forme est là j'ai travaillé fort les
deux dernières semaines il a rejeté à
jay peak avec michael wood teamspeak
olic sera aussi présent aux grands prix
cyclistes auront travaillé fort nous ont
fait souffrir avec des motos dit ok on
travaille fort pour être prêts ou les
randonnées la campagne soit tu te fais
pas de polémiques à notre convoi
merci beaucoup d'études voir souhaite la
meilleure des chances aux poudres